[BLANK_AUDIO]
[MUSIC]
But seriously, that speech was great.
>> Aw, thanks.
[LAUGH] I was actually super nervous
when they called shopping list
plus plus.
I just kind of panicked.
>> May I?
>> Yeah, sure.
>> Wow, this is elegant.
Personalized everything.
This is amazing.
>> Yeah, it's a lot heavier
than you'd think it'd be.
>> Yeah.
Hey,
have you had one of these macaroons?
>> No, I actually haven't
eaten anything all day.
I would kill for an right now.
>> I think Walter's at the store,
if there's only some way
we could contact him.
>> Hey, we could use the app.
>> Of course.
>> Here, get my phone open.
And I'll just go ahead and
scroll through my shopping list.
And Walter is in the store,
that's awesome.
So, let's go ahead and
add insta, delicious instarito.
[MUSIC]
[NOISE]
>> Wow.
Looks like he picked it up.
>> Yeah, that's super fast.
>> Yeah.
>> What do we do now?
>> Hey.
What about teach.
>> Right, let's teach this class.
>> Yeah.
>> Hey.
[LAUGH]
>> Hello there, and
welcome to Firebase Essentials for
Android.
My name is JP and I'm a program manager
for Google with Developed Training.
More recently, I've been involved with
Google's cloud courses on Udacity.
>> Hi, I'm Lyla.
I'm an android course
developer at Udacity.
I've worked on developing android apps,
as well as android for.
>> So by now,
you've probably guessed that Lyla and
her team are the creators
of shopping list plus plus,
the wildly successful collaborative
shopping list app written in firebase.
You've recently seen it in action
when Walter, Lyla's roommate,
ordered us in as instarito.
>> Right.
But what you don't know
is how we got here.
In this five lesson course,
you will take on the role of shopping
list plus pluses first developer hire.
And in doing so,
you're going to help us integrate
the Android app with a firebase backend.
>> You know, if you don't know what
firebase is, it's a platform for
building mobile and web applications
where you can read data,
create authentication methods, and also
configure security and permissions for
your data.
>> When you're done, you're going to
know how to create a app with
a backend that can support something
like a chat application or Google Docs,
or even the backend for
a multiuser game.
>> Yeah.
And
I'll be collaborating with Lyla
discussing firebase theory.
I'll also introduce some examples
that you can use when you're
building your project.
>> And I'm the course's app architect,
which means I'll be walking you through
the code examples and talking about
sort of design issues with you.
I'll also ask you to implement
features for the app.
>> So you might be wondering what
exactly do you need to know to begin
this course.
Well basically, you need to be able to
build Android apps that can connect
to the internet and read data.
You also need to understand
the Android lifecycle in UI,
specifically responsive design, and
you should know GitHub and GitRepos.
Basically, if you've completed
the developing Android apps and
completed the project for
that course, you should be fine.
>> Mm-hm.
And there's actually a couple things
that you do not need to know for
this course.
For example, you don't need to
know how to configure servers or
do anything with backends.
>> So, Lyla, one question,
what does students want to know if
this course is really for them?
>> Well, that's a great question.
And actually, we thought of that.
So, we typed up a full list of
prerequisites and you can go ahead and
check out the instructor notes for
those.
>> So I think with that, maybe this
is a good time to take a trip down
memory lane and go back in time and
see how everything began.
[MUSIC]